won't get far towards a zero carbon
energy future without a lot more of
these
huge banks of batteries connected
directly to the electricity grid
so if there's
instability in the grid or the shocks to
the system that's really where batteries
comes in and intermittent renewable
energy
is a critical part of our net zero
future
but it has to be stabilized and
batteries are one of the best ways or
probably the best way at the moment
this battery at cowley substation near
oxford is huge it can store and release
50 megawatts of electricity enough for
thousands of homes
it's pioneering too combining fast and
powerful lithium batteries with a new
type of liquid battery called a vanadium
flow cell
not quite as much umph as lithium but it
can be charged and recharged almost
infinitely without a lot of performance
it's a lower power density but it really
complements the lithium-ion battery
enabling us to not only trade power
but also manage frequency
in a much more efficient way and also
limits the wear and tear on the
lithium-ion battery
massive batteries like this are going to
be increasingly important as we put more
and more renewables onto our electricity
grid to fill in the gaps on the days
when the sun isn't shining and the wind
isn't blowing
but storage of power is also going to
become more important as our demand for
electricity rises
take electric vehicles this is europe's
most powerful electric car charging hub
connected directly to the oxford battery
just as well three cars plugged into
these superchargers at the same time
draw more power than a hundred homes
if you add the demands of electrically
powered air source heat pumps into the
mix you can start to see why electricity
demand is projected to double by 2050.
are we gonna be more storage like this
so we're gonna need a lot more grid
because um the places where we need
electricity and the big cities and the
big industrial centers are not
normally near where the new supplies of
electricity will be which is where it
tends to be really windy offshore off
the coast of scotland and while the
government has been pretty clear in
setting out its plans for low carbon
electricity generation from things like
more wind farms now it's going to
redesign the grid with all the backup
power and storage we're going to need is
less clear
we've got no time to waste but the
government has uh recently put out a
consultation on what that future
electricity market arrangements might
work
and that is a much needed step what's
really important for the new government
coming in is they do not lose any
momentum because the grid we got it at
the moment is creaking a bit it's under
pressure and therefore getting these
reforms in place is absolutely uh
getting on with it is a really urgent
pressing issue for the new government